Yeah.
Who turned this on?
Oh, am I talking to no one here,
but me and the shadow people.
Welcome to reckless disagreement. The
only show on the Internet you can trust.
I'm your host. I'm slowly starving
to death and myself made prison.
And here's a clip from Buffy the vampire
slayer where she discovers a dark
secret about an evil corporation.
The double meat medley is vegetables.
How do you know that she's
immediately offered a bribe?
You want money but instead insists
on taking a minimum wage job.
I'd really like to not be fired anymore.
Some context here,
but for the vampire slayer is a vampire
slayer and the only person standing
between the citizens of Sunnydale and a
sinister cessation of existence due to
blood sucking every second she
spends flipping burgers is a second.
Some poor schmuck is getting,
his hemoglobin is gobbled.
People died because she was too virtuous
to blackmail and multinational fast
food chain for lying to their customers.
And that is the moment that I realized
that no one in Hollywood understands
poverty or working for a living
or even money far fetched. Right?
Who could believe that?
The notorious Lee down to earth and
relatable billionaires of Hollywood hills
could possibly, you got it. You know
where I'm going? Let's just get to it.
Mana is going on.
I am new owner of alibi.
Well, we can't stay here.
Not enough money in the kid and keep the
lights on past midnight. What a B, a,
B,
and e.
Somebody broke into the bar and Stoller
seeing kids after getting laid off.
I was finally pursuing my lifelong dream,
starting my own architecture firm.
You know what really grinds my gears?
The fact that there is no point in the
TV characters life or they're terrible
decisions catch up to them.
It's just wacky adventures and gross and
competence and then they go home every
day to an amazing apartment because I
guess they started a gogurt commercial
ones. There's still air in that spot.
Yeah, dude covered my rent for years.
Now gogurt comes through. Let's talk about
the amazing home Ted marshland share.
Sharon, how I met your mother
and it's like a thought.
We don't really need to talk about it.
Looking at it,
it's probably sufficient for this point.
You're smart.
Your brain can draw
conclusions from simple images.
The most interesting example has got
to be the show shameless, which is,
let's be clear, an amazing show, but
take a look at the house they live in.
So a lot of people live in the real world.
Probably the most realistic
come I've ever seen on TV,
but listen to what flood magazine has to
say about it. Shameless is raw, honest,
and dark.
The audience can practically smell the
Fed marsh of its settings through the
screen vomit and secretion.
Our featured characters,
TV has so warped our understanding
of what life is like,
that a semi realistic depiction of
poverty is the most disgusting thing this
writer can even think of.
I wonder, would it be like to live
there and have servants and valleys?
Oh sure. People who tell you
to go and how to dress. Oh,
it's better than here. We're only
scraping for food, ducking the guards.
I understand that a movie about a genie
in a flying carpet doesn't also need to
be a sober reflection on class structure,
but maybe it's weird to say the princesses
who are sick of being told what to do,
have less to complain about that.
A guy who in his own words has got
to eat to live, got to steal the eat,
tell you all about it
when he's got the time.
Assistant Professor Jessie strive at Duke
University conducted a study of every
g rated Disney movie to make over $100
million and found that the big theme is
that inequality is benign.
Proving that what I do for a living is
just like being a professor at Duke Mom.
Also,
thanks for watching mom and Snow White
and the seven dwarves sing their way to
work every day.
The citizens of bells,
quiet provincial town love living in the
crushing poverty of 17th century France.
I know that the point is supposed to
be that money can't buy happiness,
but it ends up being that the poor
on an even footing with the rich,
which like I believe that's wrong.
You can probably find a study somewhere.
It's not just fairy tales and
the first iron man, Tony Stark.
Nobody shuts down all weapons
manufacturing in his weapons manufacturing
business and the TV tells him that
his entire corporation is doing,
but by the next movie
is closed or fancier.
His gadgets are only cooler and his
business is more profitable than ever.
Both daredevil in Sherlock are shows
about superheroes who live in really dope
apartments,
even though they only take cases they
find interesting or morally challenging in
some way. Foggy in particular
is always worried about money,
but only because he's the annoying fat
wrong character because who would worry
about money? Oh, loser.
It's way better to just put on a
mask and punch whatever you see here.
Did never owned a credit
card or leased a car. Nope.
Mason, hey, not really. One in 10
Americans have a credit score of zero.
That's 45 million people
among folks Fiona's age.
That number spikes to more like foreign
10 you can open up a credit card account,
take an advance of thousand
dollars paid back tomorrow,
and you're an excellent credit risk.
That's ridiculous to Fiona is
not an excellent credit risk.
She has no payment history and no
long longterm accounts. You know,
78% of Americans don't know that length
of credit history is an important part
of your score or that closing
off older accounts will hurt.
That score just gave you
valuable financial advice
and this comedy video that he
didn't see that coming and
full of surprises you love me.
Managing your credit properly
can give you a huge advantage,
but only if you're the type of Weirdo
who likes to own cars or homes or not pay
ridiculous interest rates. And remember,
shameless is the realistic show.
Let's go through some times
wacky characters casually
ruined their lives for a
quick joke.
So let me know that.
Listen,
I already transferred to $3,000 balance
from the valley federal card over to my
spring mills mutual card
because I had an $8,000 limit.
But since I'm already
bumping against that,
I muscle transferred everything to
yours because it has a $20,000 limit.
It's really visa,
Bill and bill up one of two.
How I met your mother went out of their
way to make Lily's credit card debt a
season long problems so you'd
think they'd think it through,
but in the end it just seemed like a point
of mild shame for the characters with
no actual long term
consequences for their lives.
Buy designer clothes and
accessories that I can't afford.
I have 15 credit cards and they're all
maxed out after Mahershala and Lilly
bought an apartment at a
ridiculous 16% interest rate.
It turned out fine instead of the kind
of thing that would ruin you forever
because Marshall just happened to stumble
into a killer high paying lawyer job,
or the only downside is that
it's evil and crushing him.
Nevermind that most people would gladly
take an evil soul crushing job in
exchange for benefits and
financial security because
the alternative is usually
an evil soul crushing job that doesn't
have benefits or security and will also
destroy you physically because you're
working with dangerous chemicals or Carter
ground.
Thousands of pounds of bricks like lifted
in his summer vacation in shameless.
Shameless is pretty good
for the most part, right?
It's not just me calling it the
best depiction of poverty and TV.
So let's talk about how shameless
mix poor people look like dicks.
Like I touched on earlier, I love
this show. It's Rad, well-written,
Emmy Rossum deserves every award,
et cetera.
But also the main joke is how
awful the characters can be.
Lip stealing the truckers.
Meat is just the beginning.
There's also the time Kevin and Veronica
had a threesome with Veronica's mom.
The time Debbie lied to her boyfriend to
trick them into getting her pregnant at
the time Frank's girlfriend jerked
lip off by touching his feet. Funny.
It's just weird.
We'll have like whole arcs about
addiction and untreated mental illness and
failed business ventures that
are treated really seriously,
but then they'll pay rent by lying about
their landlord being a pedophile and
blackmailing him for it.
The show's gimmick is how gross it gets.
And showtimes audience is mostly wealthy
people and they keep going for the
cheap laughs and I'm not proud of that
punt. So let's just finish up here.
The overall message we're sending
is that money is easy to manage and
unimportant and that poor
people are lazy and gross.
I get this is all escape his fantasy,
but finances are a pretty important topic
for everyone to consistently get this
wrong. So the question is, what
do we do about it? You know,
this is an important issue
and this is the Internet,
so we've got to take it seriously.
I know I'll ask the shadow people.
They seem to have, they're more or less
together. Come to me, my shadow friends,
we have much to discuss.
Hey,
thanks for watching our video.
Hit the scene in the middle to subscribe
and hit the little bell to be notified
when it was going to be more videos.
And then we have a comment
telling me what this does.
Nothing.
It doesn't do anything.